hi sorry I'm a little nervous this is my
first uh conference talk since before
the pandemic so it's very uh
intimidating being up here in front of
all of you not just in my living room so
but anyways my name is Natalie O'Shea um
I am an analytics consultant at betterup
we're a startup offering digital
coaching experiences uh focused on
helping people everywhere living their
lives with greater Clarity purpose and
passion my role on the people insights
team is to help develop and scale data
driven behavioral insights to support
organizational transformation at some of
the world's leading
companies on our team we're often
dealing with scenarios like this so we
might partner with an organization that
has made major publicly announced goals
to advance equity on their engineering
team for example
after years of ineffective trainings and
seminars they might turn to better up as
a data and science backed solution for
implementing and measuring their
admirable organizational transformation
goals so in this example they might have
goals for the deployment where they want
to say improve overall belonging for ERG
leaders and under represented ic's while
simultaneously improving inclusive
inclusive leadership among man
managers uh they might have a contract
stipulation that says that we need to
then map their uh better Up's whole
person model to their unique cultural
value competency framework and then they
want these results uh reported back to
them at regular business reviews to
track progress towards their
organizational transformation
goals so this is an or or this is an
account you're really excited to support
but there's one major problem
you're a CSM and you're res you're
responsible for this amazing inspiring
account which doesn't have the support
of a dedicated Behavioral Science expert
alongside 15 other amazing inspiring
accounts and based on our internal
estimates it takes the full account team
approximately 18 hours to build a single
Business Review with seven of those
hours dedicated to just navigating
different dashboards to collect the Data
Insights needed to demonstrate the
impact that coaching is having on a
partner organization's transformation
goals so rut row
indeed so this left our team with two
crucial questions the first being how do
we enable our field team to tell
compelling stories of organizational
transformation at scale with limited
subject matter expert
support and once we've master mastered
that how do we then productize those
insights and enable our partners to have
realtime insight into their own
transformational
goals so apologies for the very big
table here but you guys are all data
scientists we love tables um the current
Patchwork of analytic tools and
approaches really fails to meet our
needs for scalable self-serve reporting
in a Consulting context so in product
analytics often don't address the unique
customer needs and they often lack the
ability to tell a compelling story in
the language of the
client while on the other side of the
spectrum ad hoc customer reporting is
time consuming and difficult to scale
effectively to meet customer demand
sustainably therefore as companies we
often spend tons of time and money
building self-served analytics systems
using business intelligence tools but
we're still left with this huge burden
of effective enablement of less
technical data consumers that often
complain of information overload and
understandably so so at the end of all
of this we still have you know often
simple visualizations that lack visual
polish which is not something we're
particularly proud to share with our
clients um one alternative code-based
approach that I particularly love is
parameterized reporting and this
provides a much more customizable and
scalable end product with professional
grade data
visualizations however it often lacks
the ability to then customize in those
final stages um and really tailor
insights to the specific client goals
and
needs so ultimately none of these
approaches quite fit the mold of what
we're looking for instead we want to
bridge the gap between software as a
service and standard analytics
Consulting with a tool that is
simultaneously scalable and easy to use
while still enabling lots of Downstream
tweaking and
customization more specifically we were
looking for something that lives kind of
squarely between business intelligence
tools like looker and something like
codebase parameterized
reporting so through lots of user
interviews I learned that surprise
surprise no one really loves manually
loading and taking screenshots from 10
different dashboards to build a single
presentation instead users wanted the
convenience of self-served tools but
also the visual polish and automation
capabilities that are really only
possible with more code-based approaches
so I said porol do let's do
it so introducing betterup insights
betterup insight is a shiny app that I
built to enable scalable flexible
self-serve reporting that allows members
of our field team to select a reporting
group of Interest whether that's a
specific partner or perhaps an entire
industry which is often useful for
pre-sales motions and then generate a
Google slide deck populated with various
Data Insights um which can then be
further tweaked and modified Downstream
to help tell a really cust tailored
story of organizational transformation
in the language of the
client just like any standard business
intelligence tool data is pulled
directly from our database at the time
the user clicks load data but we go one
step further by not only generating
professional grade visualizations but
then directly sending those
visualizations and metrics to
pre-formatted Google slide decks with
several different templates including
things like inclus Ive leadership
coaching culture hybrid work and manager
Effectiveness this workflow is not only
much more efficient and enjoyable um but
it also greatly cuts down on
opportunities for human error so things
like making sure that the date the data
was pulled or end counts displayed
underneath of a a visualization in the
caption these may seem small but they
can make or break deals in an economic
environment where every single business
purchase is highly
scrutinized of course this wouldn't be
posit conf if I didn't get to geek out a
little bit about the Build architecture
of this app so here here comes the more
technical stuff but feel free to Pig me
after if you want to talk more um first
and foremost I am an early and
enthusiastic adopter of the Rhino
framework for scalable and robust shiny
apps so having developed several
Frankenstein monolithic shiny apps in
the past myself I knew I wanted to take
a module first approach um and while
I've dabbled in other module first uh uh
Frameworks like golum I really prefer to
keep my package development workflow
separate from my app development
workflow so for me I found the Rhino
framework really intuitive and a joy to
work with so if you have a similar
development mindset highly encourage you
to check it
out next I knew that I needed to
carefully manage reactivity within the
app so beyond just making some kind of
standard design choices like making sure
that we only run queries when a user
clicks an action button and not just
reactively when anything changes um I
also adopted the R6 plus Garo triggers
approach which has been advocated by Jan
hill which I link below um I found this
especially helpful because I can then
embed um small helper functions within
the r six object itself self that allow
me to do things like apply minimum data
thresholds for data privacy reasons um
in a very easy to maintain
way and then finally I was able to
integrate much of my betterup colleague
Andrew Reese's previous python workflows
for working with the Google API into my
shiny app using the reticulate package
which I am fully convinced is pure
magic so what has this unlocked for our
organization
um the apps really become a crucial
component of this emerging framework for
efficient unified and field tested
partner reporting so rather than just
kind of willy-nilly
building uh building out uh willy-nilly
Billy rynly building out product uh
analytics we really want to start with
identifying and prioritizing that
reporting need and then conducting and
uh visualiz or conducting analysis and
visualizing data before we spend the
time and effort um really building that
out to into into in product product into
in product data visualization tools so
in addition uh to you know just the
obvious efficiency gains of this
approach one additional benefit is more
strategic role alignment for our field
team members so in my initial user
interviews with members of our field
team one key theme that emerged in every
single conversation that I had was an
overwhelming desire to lean into the
more consultative elements of a sales
role so users of the app wanted to spend
less time copying and pasting data from
one channel to another so they could
instead focus on surfing surfacing
business relevant insights and
recommendations for our partners and
maybe surfing as well but maybe only in
California I'm in Minnesota so no
surfing for
me all right so ultimately betterup in
insights was somewhat of a trojan horse
for getting our or our organization to
adopt posit products um and as I was
telling some colleagues last night um I
came into this role with admittedly a
bit of an
agenda this was not my first time trying
to advocate for posit products to be
procured at my company but it was in
fact my first time being successful in
that endeavor so I'd like to spend the
remainder of my talk sharing some
insights I gleaned through this process
so that you might be able to take a
similar approach for building the
business case at posit at your
organization so perhaps the most
important Insight that I gained was that
you need to identify a core capability
that these products will unlock for your
organization so what can what capability
can you uniquely provide that's not
already present in existing tools so
figure that out do do it and do it well
so one Pitfall that many of us including
myself fall into is being overly
enthusiastic about the full range of
possibilities that you would be able to
unlock if only you had posit so
dashboards multiple idees easy API
deployment scheduled reports just the
possibilities are
endless um bring that enthusiasm here to
posit conf but save it for the
boardroom uh in
you know instead focus on one unique
capability um and that has to have a
clear impact on your organization's
bottom
line equally if not more important build
your team as open source enthusiasts we
often know how to harness the power of
code-based tools but then struggle to
communicate and gain Buy in from the
right people so this is why I believe
that cultivating A diversity of
relationships is the key to procurement
success so be Kermit the Frog have a
creative vision and no ego recognize the
unique talents of those around you and
attract your organization's
weirdos but in all seriousness it's
important not to over anchor on any one
stakeholder
perspective so for example your business
person is going to know how to best
navigate your organizational hierarchy
gain buyin uh obtain resources
uh whereas your more engineering minded
folks are going to have a better
understanding of where posit and your
specific data products are going to fit
into the overall software development
life cycle not to mention those people
are probably the people you're going to
need to tap when you actually need to
get posit up and running on your
company's data
infrastructure you'll also want to
develop strong relationships with your
customers themselves so the people that
you are building this product uh with
and
for so I highly recommend doing
extensive user interviews with these
people which is a great way not only to
just clarify the problem you're trying
to solve but also uh simultaneously
build relationships and trust with your
most crucial
stakeholders and if you're lucky you'll
find someone to fill every one of these
roles listed here but let's be honest uh
it might just be you or one or two
additional people that are willing to go
to bath with you um in this case it's
still helpful to be aware of these roles
so that you can know which hat to wear
at any given
time this next point is related to that
core capability point at the start so
when making the case forit at your
organization it helps to think not in
terms of what question can I answer but
what service can I provide so I.E create
a data product so while dashboards
answer questions data products perform
valuable services and that's ultimately
what's going to get you through all of
your procurement effort hurdles which
you will inevitably face so relatedly
data products must be built with
maintainability and robusticity in mind
um which means that you need to think
like a software engineer in order to win
the war for limited software engineering
budget so all too often I see other data
scientists building Scrappy prototypes
and analyses with poor code practices
which is fine for an industrial
idation um but if we ever intend to be
viewed as a real component of the
product development life cycle we need
to at least demonstrate a good faith
effort at applying um standard software
engineering best
practices uh so things like a full
continuous integration and deployment
pipeline might be Overkill but just
simply backing up your code and get and
at least thinking about things like
dependency management um should be on
your radar
and I have a little my one little rant
of the day is some data scientists I've
met uh seem to think this is overly
burdensome or encroaching on their
creative process and if you feel that
way I urge you to check out a talk that
I link at the bottom there which is uh
science's amateur software development
by Richard M elth um I think he makes a
great case that it's a testament to the
power of science that we're able to
discern any meaningful patterns at all
given uh sence scientist chaotic
development practices so science manages
to provide reliable knowledge in spite
of not because of uh these practices so
rant over moving
on so my final piece of advice um for
anyone looking to make the case for
boset is you need to measure impact so
for us this started with a baseline ROI
analysis which estimated the time cost
savings for our organiz organization to
be about $1.2 million a year in time
cost savings and that was enough to make
the case for better up to procure
deposit pro
products but unfortunately your journey
is not over once uh the procurement
process ends so once installed and
deployed you'll need to continue to
demonstrate the impact these tools are
having on your organization so tracking
usage um and collecting user feedback
can be a big part of that um for user
feedback you you know that will not only
help you prioritize new feature
developments but it can also just bring
joy to you on a rainy day
so here are some screenshots of my
colleagues reactions when we first
released betterup insights to the people
insights team at betterup so as you can
see there's a lot of joy to be had in
making your colleagues daily workflows
more easy and efficient um so perhaps my
favorite little nugget here um was at
the end of a feature enhancement request
where someone signed off thank you in
advance posit
obsessed um and I don't know about you
but I've never had a non-technical
stakeholder call themselves looker or
powerbi obsess so throwing in a little
shade there
but um finally I'd like to thank uh
several people at better up that I
absolutely could not have done this
without I could go on and on about them
but I'm seeing I'm at time here um and
finally uh let's connect so you can find
me on LinkedIn or Mastadon and if you're
wondering why Rihanna is on this slide
it's because uh if you've seen me
bopping around the conference and
wondered to yourself um is she pregnant
or did she eat just a massive Chipotle
burrito um the answer is the former and
for me giving a talk at posit conf is
basically my nerdy equivalent of like
performing at the Super
Bowl so hence the meme so that's it for
me thank
you
all right thank you Natalie uh got time
for one quick question actually so um
how do you find how do you best Define
the necessary capability when you're
trying to decide to develop uh that has
to be developed in like in discussion
with your stakeholders so I you would
have to know the specific you know
problems at your organization what are
the things that are people most
complaining about is what I would say
fantastic so know your room thank you
again